[Music]
sanim number two how'd you guys meet Oh
waxing his business oh my god it looks
like a parking it was an interesting
thing it was like hi how are you good to
meet you Catherine and legs go up and
here we go let's do this working with
her is is a treat she is a genius when
it comes to comedic timing and all
that's improv E and she never breaks and
she's just the constant of pro so like
sort of working with her and also
watching and learning at the same time
was fun I mean that like you walk into a
room and you see you know Mila Kunis and
Susan Sarandon is there and Kristen
Bell's there and Catherine Hansa it's
just like one after the other after the
other and and they're all so talented
and funny and they're having a great
time and and to jump into the second one
as well
it's kind of cool because you see the
camaraderie already between the ladies
and then you know come in and do this
really fun fun part for a few days it's
great Justin Hartley dishing on his role
in the bad mom sequel he chatted with
him at Esquires Mavericks of style and
Hugo Boss event where he also spilled on
this is us season two is Kevin ready to
be a dad I don't think that's where
we're headed but I don't I would say not
he's he's just sort of crossed over that
sort of getting is getting his life
together you know and and I don't know
if he would if you'd be ready to be a
dad right now but we'll see what happens
meanwhile Justin is getting ready for a
life-changing experience of his own he's
getting married two days of our lives
actress crucial Styles I mean it's kind
of cool like to be able to call her wife
that's kind of neat you know and to be
referred to as husband that's kind of
cool
[Music]
you